hi my name is Carol and with magic I
would like to share our experience with
building this large-scale ecommerce
recommender system and the system we are
about to present recommends product by
finding nearest neighbors enlightened
spies and to do this we need a high
quality product embeddings hence the
title of this presentation before going
into the details of the system let me
briefly introduce our company and basic
taxonomy of recommender systems so
Allegro is an online marketplace it's
not an online store so it does not it
does not sell products but provide a
platform for third-party sellers to sell
their product and there are almost
400,000 sellers and this makes Allegro
the largest the largest e-commerce in
Poland and in fact it's also the sixth
largest in Europe in European Union
Union in terms of turnover but it's
operates only in Poland and just to give
you some idea that there are numbers
give you some idea of the scale there is
there are some numbers so we have 20
million accounts and over 100 million
offers or items the number of unique
products is smaller because there are
some duplicates some products are being
sold by multiple sellers some products
are being sold under different names and
recommender systems we distinguish two
main categories a collaborative
filtering and content based and this
term collaborative filtering has two
meanings one narrow one and one broad or
generic one and in a narrow one
collaborative filtering is just an
algorithm to predict writings user gift
items and in this broader one it's a
family of algorithms that predict future
user behaviors based on past user
behaviors and further around in this
presentation we will use collaborative
filtering in this in this broader in
this broader sense and we define two
subtypes of collaborative filtering
namely item to item so when you
recommend
product product similar products with a
given product and user to item when you
recommend products to a user profile or
and we can build those systems either
based on explicit or implicit feedback
in case of e-commerce it's much easier
to build it based on implicit feedback
because this kind of feedback is it's
much easier to collect and the second
type is content-based systems those
systems basically recommend product by
finding similar products in in the sense
of content and by content we mean either
title or description or parameters or
images of product and the question is
which of those two is better and in
general collaborative filtering at scale
always win
I mean we tested it multiple times maybe
test and at scale always collaborative
filtering wins but sometimes we
explicitly prefer content based for
example in fashion we want to recommend
similar dresses or similar shoes based
on images and sometimes we cannot use
complex collaborative filtering because
to do this we need some a number of past
activities associated with product and
for new products we do not have those
activities and also for old product I
mean for products that exist in our
platform for a longer time we sometimes
do not have enough number of activities
because there is this relatively small
number of products that are frequently
visited purchased and a long tail of
products that are rarely visited so we
cannot recommend products for those for
this long time so the common strategy is
to use collaborative filtering whenever
it's possible and fall back on content
base when it's not possible to use
collaborative filtering and the question
is can we do better and yes later on we
will describe a strategy how to
recommend using those crafts base method
or behavioral methods for those freshly
added products as well okay and
recommendations are important for
e-commerce and follower glass well a
lacrosse well
they generate around 10% of total sales
so and we have around 33 placements or
Caruso's or shelves the same name
different names for the same thing and
those shelves or carousels are available
on desktop and mobile applications and
in email campaigns as well and you can
see you can see just shirts of those
placements and shirts by total sales and
the important takeaway from this slide
is that three out of four most important
shells or carousels are located on the
product page therefore those item to
item recommendations are of high
importance for us more they're more
important for us than user to item user
to item is only or mainly presented on
the main page but majority of users end
up in our platform they are directly
redirected from Google search so and you
can just have a look at example product
page there are two main power results
one recommends product for the same
seller and one I'm sorry and one for all
the sellers in the platform and here is
a fragment of the main page and as I
said on main page we provide a user to
item recommendations they are not as
profitable but still we want to inspire
users who come to our platform without
any specific purpose and we divide those
shelves into most frequently visited I
mean categories the user visited in the
past okay hi everyone so now let's take
a look at our solution so our design
consists of four main parts the first
one is the ETL module which is
responsible for preparing the training
dataset the second one is the embedding
model deep representation learning model
which actually gives us the embeddings
the third
is the nearest neighbor search module
which actually gives us the
recommendations based on the embeddings
and the fourth one is the real time
serving model so let me begin with the
ETI module well different scenarios
different business scenarios placements
require different recommendation logic
hence we need to extract different data
and in case of collaborate filtering we
extract the either sequences of visited
product IDs from user sessions extracted
from clickstream data or we rely on
transactional data like purchases and
cards to obtain recommendations on a
complimentary basis in case of
content-based recommenders
which are often our fallback
recommenders we extract product titles
category paths and product images from
our product database in order to do this
we implemented several SEO jobs SEO is a
scholar wrapper around Apache beam Java
not Python API and it gives us really
concise syntax strong typing and good
testability and we highly recommend this
tool this was the first part the data
preparation part now let's take a look
at one of the two pillars of our
solution namely the embeddings model the
key idea of our system - is to find the
latent space representation for products
available on our platform or in plain
English to convert products to real
valued vectors multi-dimensional vectors
the dimensions of this of this space do
not have any human reputation what you
care about most is that they should
preserve item similarity so similar
products should have similar embeddings
and by similar embeddings we usually
mean low cosine distance so as you can
see an iPhone has its representation and
eye path which is something
quite similar has a quite similar
embolic while a pair of sneakers has its
vector direct in a totally different
different direction this is the theory
and how can we obtain such vector such
representations well in order to do it
we use an algorithm which originates
from natural language processing is
called word Tyvek presented in 2013 and
it comes in two flavors the first called
continuous bag of words or Cibao tries
to learn how to predict a central word
given surrounding or context words the
second flavor called skip gram is a dual
version it tries to predict the context
words given a central word and we
actually use this second version okay so
we have we know how to obtain word
embeddings but how do we obtain product
embeddings the transition and the answer
is surprisingly simple it's called the
prod to Veck and the only thing we have
to do is to actually change the
vocabulary so we we use sentences we use
user sessions and those words we use
product IDs the rest stays the same
this way using skip Graham we can
predict the surrounding products given a
central product for for instance the one
you're currently watching so the true
aim of our model is to learn to predict
surrounding products given the central
product there's nothing about
recommendations in this in this at this
stage we rely on a system-wide implicit
feedback so we don't restrict ourselves
to data generated by recommender system
in the past we rely on the entire click
stream and by doing so we reduce the
bias from past recommendations and we
have much more training data it is
important to notice that the product and
bearings here are in fact side-effects
of the training process of the word
feedback model
it is also important to say that word
Tuvok actually implicitly decomposes the
item to write an interaction matrix and
it does it in a way that has a
relatively low memory footprint and it's
quite resilient to data sparsity which
is a huge problem in our setting and we
will discuss it later so suppose we have
some a embedding a set of a mapping a
set of a set of vectors so is the good
embedding is it better than the random
set of vectors the one desire to
property of embedding is that it
preserves item similarity so similar
items should have similar vectors and
the graph you see behind me is actually
shows a sample of products on Allegro
colored by their top-level category and
you can clearly see a the separation
between these categories another desired
property of embeddings
is that it should preserve relations
between items and now for for a second
let's pretend and that Allegra sells
only men's shoes women's shoes many
clubs and women clubs and these items
have at least two orthogonal aspects the
gender of the product and the type of
the product is it a shoe or is it
clothes and this this graph shows this
subset of products projected onto 2d and
you can clearly see these two aspects
along the vertical and horizontal axis
so finding such relations gave us some
confidence that our vectors are
something valuable so as I previously
mentioned different placements require
different recommend a recommender logic
and on product pages we in general we
want to show similar products in order
to obtain this effect we train on
sequences of pay product pages while in
cart and some post by emails we want to
show complementary products and in order
to achieve this we train on
transactional data so the
stay the same what changes is the input
all I've just said refers to a
collaborative filtering recommenders and
as Carol mentioned there are some
sometimes we cannot use these methods so
we fall back on a content-based
recommenders and basically we use two
types of them one based on text and one
based on product images so in case of
text we learn two representations of
individual words present in product
titles using fast text and then we
combine these representations in order
to get the vector of the product title
in case of images we use a deep neural
network inception be free free trained
on image net data set and then
fine-tuned by our colleagues from other
team on Allegro products okay once we
have a high quality product embeddings
we need to turn them into
recommendations and to do this we need
nearest neighbors search module on
component this component is a second
pillar of our system the knife naive
approach would be to do this would be to
calculate distances between a query
product and or remaining products then
sort all those products and select a few
nearest neighbors but this is very
expensive it would take too much time it
would be infeasible in practice so we
need some approximation and of course
approximation introduces some errors in
approximations not as good as this exact
method or brute search brute-force
search approach but some type of errors
is acceptable for us what we care is a
high precision of results we can
compromise on on recall so there is this
saying that what the eye doesn't see the
hurt doesn't grip over
so we basically follow this principle
and we focus to I mean we try to have to
not to have false positives
if we have some pop false negatives
there is no problem for us because what
we care is to have relevant
recommendations for a given product if
some relevant products are not presented
on this shelf or carousel the user does
not know about it so yeah there's there
are many approximate nearest neighbor
search algorithms most of them can
retrieve those neighbors in almost
constant time very quickly and probably
the most popular is random hyperplane
projection also known as locality
sensitive sensitive locality sensitive
hashing and the idea is just to split
search space with random hyperplanes
to form hyper cubes and then the most
similar product or in general mostly are
vectors in original vector space will
end up in the same hypercube so in order
to retrieve those similar vectors we
just need to browse through this
hypercube maybe a few nearby hyper cubes
hyper cubes and this algorithm sips is
implemented by popular libraries fortify
annoyed and at the beginning we were
using this library but then we switch to
Facebook vise vices similar library but
it has a few advantages for example it
is jupiler gpu-accelerated and a few
words how files works so basically it
implements a two-stage searching
strategy so at the beginning you need to
train our index and during this training
all the vectors are clustered into
relatively small number of partitions
also known as Voronoi cells and each of
those partitions is represented by a
centroid centroid centroid which is just
a mean of vectors within this cluster
and at search time what we do we just
retrieve the most similar
Voronoi cells and this way we narrow
significantly narrow search space and
then in this narrow search space we can
we can afford exact search or brute
force search because the search space is
much smaller now yeah we could introduce
even further speed-up and reduce the
memory requirements even more by using
some more advanced quantization
techniques files implements those more
sophisticated quantization techniques
but in our case it was just enough to
use this two-stage strategy without more
advanced quantization techniques but
there are there's the pipe error which
describes those ideas and humor details
how this nearest neighbors nearest
neighbor search module works or is
implemented so basically for
collaborative filtering recommendations
we built just one big files index
because there is relatively there's I
mean we can build this this index and
for content based it was too big I mean
to put all 100 million embeddings into
one files index we could not find a big
enough machine in GCP so we decided to
split to split and build a separate
files indices for every top-level
category we have around 20 of those
top-level product categories in on our
platform and also one important thing is
that we do not want to those neighbors
to be too similar to original to the
query product because often we end up
with you know almost the same product we
want some diversity in recommendation is
desired so we introduced some minimal
Delta or minimal distance between a
query product and remaining products and
also between pairs of products of the
neighbor list and yeah
of course to select this Delta this
Delta can be treated as a hyper
parameter so it's not easy to to select
to select good
Delta good minimal distance it have to
be done in some experimental way also
one important thing is that we eagerly
precompute all recommendations so for
all the products in our on our platform
we eagerly precompute daily
recommendations I mean we could do this
we could retrieve those neighbors in
online fashion but but in most cases
it's enough to do this offline and then
serve just precomputed recommendations I
will talk about this later on a little
bit ok those three modules describe till
now run in an public cloud and we need
some orchestration tool to to run those
to you know to schedule to schedule
those tasks and we use Spotify Luigi
it's a similar library as patchy are low
there are two concepts two main concepts
the concept of task and concept of
target and every task has multiple
inputs and one output and if some input
is missing then the scheduler scheduler
is scheduling tasks that produced that
produced those inputs and this way the
whole graph of dependencies is built in
luigi is easily extendable we
implemented a few custom tasks and
targets for example to submit a cloud
machine learning tasks or Google data
flow task ok and serving as I said at
serving time we just retrieve
precomputed recommendation from read
oriented key value store in our case
it's Cassandra so we store a lot of
those source to target relations but of
course before returning recommendations
to user we need to enrich those set of
IDs with some metadata descriptions
images just to form you know ready to be
presented set of recommendation and also
we need to exclude we need to filter out
some elements because if recommendations
are built daily then after
those recommendations are precomputed
some product can be no longer available
at our platform so we need to check
before returning recommendations the
user to a user whether their products
are still available ok ranking is very
important in information retrieval most
of the search engines apply some sort of
muscle of learning to rank ranking on
top of result returned from let's say
inverted list search engines and in case
of a lager or learning to rank improves
results by 10% so we wanted to apply the
same idea to recommendations and in fact
in recent years there are many papers
that prove that that it's it's it's good
idea to apply learning to rank ranking
on top of some recommendation system and
we experiment with this but it's not I
mean not every placement has already
this strategy applied in our company but
we we experiment with this learning to
rank on top of nearest neighbors search
recommendation system ok at the
beginning I told you that and also magic
mentioned that we serve collaborative
filtering whenever we can and we fall
back on content base when there is not
enough events past events associated
with product and we wanted to do better
basically to be able to recommend those
behavioral recommendations for every
product even for products that do not
have past activities so in order to do
this we introduced it concept of proxy
product let's say so we built so we for
for for those products that do not have
activities associated with them does not
have do not have past histories we
retrieve nearest neighbor in content
space but narrowed to only popular items
so this way we retrieve proxy product
proxy neighbor and this neighbor already
has
activities so we can serve collaborative
filtering recommendations even for
products that that are recently added
freshly added to the platform on the
bottom of this slide you you can see a
diagram that describe this idea
basically one additional auxiliary files
index is needed to do this ok the second
approach we also experimented with that
tries to solve the same problem is
Metapod two back to this idea described
in this paper so basically instead of
training skip gram on just product IDs
as magic described earlier we enrich
those sessions with metadata identifiers
so we can do this only for categorical
metadata like let's say color and of
course we need to extend window size
because you know those sessions are
extended so we need proportionally
extend the size of the window and as a
coach as a consequence there are two
consequences of this idea the first
product embeddings are have better
quality now because for example product
with the same metadata let's say red
product are somehow somehow are drawn
together in the vector space the second
benefit is that we obtain metadata
embeddings and those embeddings are
embedded in the same vector space and we
can for for freshly added product we can
take their embeddings find or lookup and
I mean take metadata of those freshly
added product lookup embeddings of those
metadata and find nearest neighbors I
mean if and find products
that are near those metadata
I hope it's maybe it's not clear you can
read this paper it's it's it's clearly
this idea is described in this paper and
we experimented with this idea as well
but the first idea the first the first
strategy I described on the previous
slide is our main let's say hybrid
recommendation strategy okay what about
the user so far we've talked only about
item to item recommendations which is
reasonable given the share of product
pages in other girl traffic but still we
want to be able to serve recommendations
directly to the user so these
recommendations differ but they differ
from item to item recommendations by at
least two to intuit
in at least two ways the first one is
that there is no explicit product
context we have to rely on the some sort
of user profile and the second one is
that it has slightly different aim the
aim is to inspire users to make new
purchases and not to shorten the
so-called path to purchase as it is in
the case of item to item recommendations
also this recomm user to item
recommendations are applicable to email
campaigns so how do we how can we obtain
such user title recommendations given
our setup and our setting and our item
vectors so the first the most ambitious
the cleanest approach is to simply learn
the latent representation of user the
same way we learned latent
representation of the items this would
mean that we have to somehow decompose
hypothetical user to item interaction
matrix but in our setting we believe it
is impossible to do because we cannot do
it in the real time and this is the
whole trick we want these
recommendations to update in real time
as the user browses different items and
he or she returns to the main page we
would like to
see recommendations relevant to the
latest latest query latest search or
recently visited items and we cannot
recompute the the entire we cannot
perform this decomposition in the real
time but still it's good and applicable
to email campaigns the okay so this is
the first first approach the second one
is to the one we're currently
experimenting with is to obtain the user
representation as an aggregation of
representations of products so yeah like
like a sum or an average this this in
this in turn requires an online nearest
neighbor search because the query
vectors will be unpredictable we cannot
predict every possible browsing history
so this requires an online online search
and the challenge here is to keep the
latency as low as possible because we no
longer can pre-compute
everything we have to actually find that
we find the nearest neighbors real time
the third option the simplest one which
actually runs in production now is to
have no reviews representation at all I
mean we simply interleave item to item
representations of the visited items
it's easy to implement fast to serve at
runtime the complexity here is how to
the problem here is to how to mix how to
interleave these recommendations
originating from different visited items
now I'd like to share a couple of
considerations and conclusions we we
learned during the development of this
system so first one is hyper parameter
tuning whenever you have a machine
learning model you probably have to tune
some hyper parameters and the tuning
does in fact in improve the quality of
your of your result in our case of our
recommendations we were lucky enough
that there is some literature on this
topic first of all there is this great
paper called hyper parameters matter and
it describes how to tune the parameters
of war to vac exactly in the context of
recommendations we follow this paper we
managed to recreate some of its results
and it indeed
in significantly improve the quality of
our recommendations we carried out this
hyper parameter tuning process the
following quake we simply held out some
number of training sessions we we
trained the model on the remaining part
and then we try to predict the last item
given the panel teammate one from this
from these hold up sessions and we
optimized the m RR at 25 which is the
length of the shelf
aka character in our system initially we
perform this procedure in Google Cloud
ml engine which is a very convenient
tool but it turned out to be quite
expensive the next trial runs we run
them with in static on static instances
using hyper up the library and it gives
us similar results but it turned out to
be much much cheaper so I recommend this
approach okay so other part is are some
data considerations and challenges they
are highly specific to our scenario
namely on line Allegro is an online
marketplace not an online store so there
are many sellers and the same product
can be offered by multiple sellers and
despite a huge effort to match offers to
products most of the offers don't have a
product ID so we don't have we don't
know that two separate offers actually
refer to the same product say say an
iPhone and discuss a lot of problems and
then the biggest problem is the decrease
in the quality of recommendations
because if we recommend on a pair of
basis we get some noise because
accidental co-occurrences become
relatively strong in the context of a
particular seller
moreover the data grows big the
dictionary of ids for which we compute
the representations is is very large and
it's simply problematic so we what we
try to do is to we try to match the
unmatched
into some pseudo products or groups of
offers we do it by title or by category
or by some set of attributes in general
we want less objects and a denser
interaction matrix because we've proven
that product based recommendations give
us much better results by simply
changing the way of the type of objects
on which we operate with the same
algorithm we managed to increase the
click-through rate by almost half and
revenue by almost a third no algorithm
offers two products but in this scenario
there is a new problem namely the choice
of the representant of a given product
name we have to choose the best offer
for product from our similarity model
and we can do it by choosing the
cheapest one into the three the free
delivery and so on in general we plan to
solve this issue using the rear ranking
algorithms one slide yeah last slide
suggests the key takeaways so we
introduced you describe the relatively
simple yet production-ready and large
scale ecommerce recommender system and
the system is based on this framework
with clearly defined modules and it can
run either in public cloud on on-premise
and we use it for both collaborative
filtering and content-based
recommendations and yeah maybe that's
all just one yeah so thank you very much
and if you have any questions
[Applause]
thanks for a great talk you mentioned
briefly bias when representation
learning in terms of the user sessions
presumably though still people are
clicking from one product to the next
using the sort of similar items that
you're already showing presumably it's
really hard to eliminate completely
eliminate that bias do you do you have
any other sort of strategies to deal
with that do you find it's a it's a
problem yes the name may needn't the
main trick to mitigate this problem is
to not to rely on only on interactions
originating from past recommender system
these parts rendered by recommender
system but on the entire traffic which
includes some you know static creations
the search engine and so and so forth so
I'm sure that the bias is still there
but it's not the bias
originating from the recommender system
probably some sort of a mixture of you
know bias from the search engine and
other you know aspects
Thank You Roger talk have you tried
using any of the latest Jensen features
like Poincare embedding so Ward movers
distance and did it find them applicable
in this industry no we didn't we're
happy to learn about these features
later you have a whole bunch of
questions so I'm gonna like come and see
you guys later
but I guess one that I asked now is you
said that when you were doing the user
item you embeddings you guys had three
different options and you chose one
which was no use of representation but
you interleave sort of item item
representations I just wasn't entirely
sure what your interleaving is hoping
you could expand on what it was that in
terms of anyway the trick is simple do
we have a we have a internal database of
things we have we have browsed and we
have item to item recommendations for
those things so the strategy is to take
the your last visited item and mix it
with recommendations from you know the
penultimate and and so and so forth and
the question is here is how do you
interpret these items basically we take
the strategy he now is very simple we
just take the first recommendation from
the last item the first recommendation
from the penultimate one and so on so
forth end and then we take the second
recommendation from the first item and
so and so forth and it performs
reasonably well
[Applause]